autre changement on va peut retrouver le
capteur d'empreintes digitales situé à
l'arrière de l'appareil
au contraire sur les modèles s 10 et s10
plus on va avoir un capteur d'empreintes
digitales
[Musique]
salut de retour au studio pour vous
parler aujourd'hui des futurs samsung
galaxy s disent qu'ils vont être
présenté le 20 février prochain à san
francisco il rossi en relais à londres
et à séoul personnellement je serais
heureux les à londres ça me fout de
m'inviter merci beaucoup
ça ne sont que ce sera mon premier run
pag deux chansons dont je suis hyper
hyper hyper content donc aujourd'hui je
vous parlais de ces nouveaux samsung
galaxy s 10 parce qu'effectivement il
devrait y avoir trois nouveaux modèles
ont été habitués à voir un modèle un peu
standard est un modèle plus simple le
plus grand peut plus boosté la vente va
voir justement trois modèles un mot des
stands à un modèle un peu plus grands un
peu plus boosté et un modèle un peu plus
light
en tout cas un peu moins cher un peu
plus abordable un petit peu dans l'idée
de ce qu'a fait apple l'année dernière
avec son iphone glisse s10 s max et son
iphone 10 r voilà un petit peu elle
l'idée parce que ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est qu'il ya un vrai enjeu
stratégique derrière pour samsung
il devrait monter en puissance des
marques chinoises huawei en tête
xiaot mis au pot et tous les autres qui
poussent derrière et on voit que a
contrario il y as par un déclin le terme
est pas vrai mais en tout cas il ya une
baisse de la part de marques historiques
vendeur de smartphones historiques que
sont apple et samsung
la concurrence chinoise est plus
agressive pour les marques historiques
c'est un peu plus dur et en plus les
ventes diminuent
il ya beaucoup moins de renouvellement
de smartphones que fut une époque tout
ça c'est une équation petit peu
compliqué pour une marque comme samsung
il faut donc continuer d'innover il faut
des modèles hyper forme en ce début
d'année est justement on va voir de
quelle manière ils répondent avec ces
nouveaux samsung galaxy s 10 s10 plus et
s10 es10 wright
donc la question c'est de savoir de
quelle manière samsung doit répondre en
gros comment doivent être ses nouveaux
modèles ces nouveaux galaxy s disent
déjà doivent répondre aux standards
actuels c'est à dire avoir des écrans de
plus en plus grand pour le multimédia
pour visionner des vidéos et aussi pour
le jeu vidéo il devrait toujours plus
optimisée pour la partie photo on
déblaie dunkerque avec le s9 s9 plus
appareil photo à ouverture variable
ça c'est très bien ils vont continuer à
aller dans ce sens en proposant des
appareils photos toujours plus
intéressant en ayant des performances
toujours optimale en ayant une autonomie
toujours au top et en proposant une
expérience utilisateur complètement
optimisé
ça ce sont les lignes directrices en
tout cas c'est là dessus à mon avis que
ça me sont balisés pour avoir un peu son
équation gagnante
regardons un peu maintenant du côté de
la fiche technique pour essayer de voir
à quoi vont ressembler ces modèles alors
je me disais trois modèles qui vont être
un peu différent entre la partie light
la partie s 10e et la partie s10 s10
plus ces deux modèles dont vraiment se
ressembler pour les 10 elles se disent
plus on va avoir un écran super amoled
bord à bord dans tous les cas on va voir
l'écran infiniti haut avec la petite
encoche avec le petit trou c'est ce que
je vous ai montré sur la miniature sur
ce tout petit bout de papier qui n'est
pas du tout aller cher ce que vous allez
donc avoir un tout petit trouve pas si
vous le voyez juste là là ici pour le
modèle light et pour le s10 tandis que
sur le s10 plus vous allez avoir un
double module photo à l'avant sans voir
pas une cicatrice instant et sur le s10
eux on va avoir un écran amoled d'un
d'écrans plats pas de bords incurvés en
gros il pourrait ressembler à l'iphone
10r qu'apple a présenté fin d'année
dernière pour le disent on va avoir un
écran de 6,1 pouces standard s10 plus
entre 6 4 à 6,5 pouces aussi un petit
peu standard par rapport aux modèles
plus que pouvait retrouver précédemment
tandis que sur le s 10e on devrait
trouver un d'écran de 5,8 pouces parce
qu'il ya encore beaucoup d'amoureux de
ce petit format qui veulent pas
forcément des écrans toujours plus grand
au niveau de la révolution devrait avoir
du quad hd + et un ratio de 10 9 9e
forcément vu qu'on va voir l'écran
infiniti haut avec ce petit point
sondages
on a gagné en partie visible sur l'écran
donc un ratio toujours plus grand
au niveau des performances comme sur
chaque année il va y avoir deux modèles
différents un modèle avec l'exynos 9820
pour le monde entier et pour le canada
et pour les usa on aura le snapdragon de
qualcomm le 855 au niveau de la ram
femme modèle s10e on veut avoir une
version 4 gigas de ram tandis que sur le
s10 on devrait avoir une version 6 giga
de ram et sur le s10 plus une version 6
ou 8 gigas de ram et là où c'est
intéressant c'est qu'en fonction des
pays on pourra voir sur le modèle s 10
soit 6 giga de ram soit même carrément
un modèle avec 8 gigas de ram ça ça va
dépendre des pays je ne suis pas sûr
qu'en europe on est un modèle à huit
gigabyte peut-être plus en asie tandis
que son modèle est 10 plus haut pour
avoir un modèle qui pourra aller jusqu'à
même 12 giga de ram une fois de plus je
pense vraiment à l'asie l'europe
à mon avis j'y crois moyennement et on
devrait aussi avoir une énorme batterie
de 4100 milliampères heures ça c'est
intéressant parce que va y avoir une
pointe technique parce qu'on va avoir un
smartphone qui sera beaucoup plus fin
que le s9 s9 plus de l'année dernière
par contre une batterie plus grosse
meilleure autonomie en tout cas ça
devrait être vraiment intéressant
en plus de ça il devrait y avoir un truc
intéressant il deviendra la prise en
charge du wifi si ce qui permettra
d'avoir des connexions toujours plus
rapide toujours plus de débit et à côté
de ça consommer toujours moins d'énergie
maintenant parlons de l'épineuse
question de la photo vidéo mais surtout
la photo parce qu'on voit que c'est un
point qui est vraiment mis en avant pour
comparer les smartphones l'année
dernière avec le s9 et s9 plus on avait
effectivement cet appareil photo
ouverture variable car franchement fait
parler lui même si les ventes ds9 s9
plus a priori donc à quelle hauteur des
attentes de samsung en face on va qu'on
a un constructeur comme huawei cas
vraiment misé sur la partie appareil
photo avec notamment le pédant pro
l'année dernière puis le mail d'un pro
en fin d'année dernière la samsung se
doit de réagir
hyper fort avec un des modèles phares
avec des belles innovations et avec des
appareils photos complètement dingue
si effectivement ils veulent récupérer
l'id on pense notamment sur la partie
photo pixels 3 mpixels 3xl de google qui
ont franchement mis là bas hyper hot
avec juste un seul appareil photo on va
commencer par le modèle light le s10 eux
on devrait avoir un double module photo
à l'arrière et un seul module photo à
l'avant un peu standard ça devrait bien
fonctionner ça n'a pas que l'appareil
photo le plus dingue
si on veut tout arrive quelque chose de
beaucoup plus énorme on va aller sur les
s10 s10 plus avec des triples module
photo pour les s10 s10 plus à l'arrière
on devrait avoir un grand-angle de 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.9 à 123 degrés pour effectivement
capter tout ce que vous voulez autour de
vous ça s'appelle franchement cool un
appareil photo principale qu'on connaît
déjà le fameux 12 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 2.4 af 1.5 excellent en
conditions de faible luminosité et un
zoom de 13 mégapixels avec une ouverture
de f 2.4 tout en sachant que le zoom et
l'appareil photo principale auront tous
les deux de l'autofocus et une
stabilisation optique de l'image
maintenant la vraie différence entre la
f10 l'es10 plus vont se faire au niveau
du module photo à l'avant sur les dix
vous aurez un simple module photo tandis
que sur le s10 plus vous aurez un double
module photo un appareil photo standard
et un appareil photo grand angle qui
permettra d'abord a défait boké optique
et en plus de ça sur la caméra de celle
filles vous devriez pouvoir filmer
jusqu'à quatre cas ça ça peut être pas
mal et tout ça avec une stabilisation
optique
autre changement on va peut retrouver le
capteur d'empreintes digitales situé à
l'arrière
aïe au contraire sur les modèles s 10 c
est 10 plus on va avoir un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée à l'écran
un capteur à ultrasons ça c'est
franchement cool bourse et notamment que
qualcomm avec son ancien dragon 855
prendre en charge ces capteur
d'empreintes digitales à ultrasons donc
ça c'est franchement où c'est une
excellente nouvelle
le gros point différence que vous avez
avec le capteur d'empreinte digitale
intégrée notamment sur un dernier modèle
de au pot où certains des modèles
deviennent plus sereine plus east et
c'est que celui ci va être beaucoup plus
rapide
on sait que c'est un petit peu le point
de reproches bon j'ai pu faire en tout
cas sur les tests des différents capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran ça marche mais il faut attendre
un petit peu est bon des fois ça marche
mais bon c'est pas complètement illégal
là par contre vous devriez poser votre
doigt ça devrait aller aussi vite que le
capteur d'empreintes digitales un peu
plus standard vous aviez positionné à
l'arrière d'un smartphone
et ça pour le coup ça devrait
franchement bien calé à noter que sur le
samsung galaxy s 10e modèle lite vous
n'aurez pas le capteur d'empreinte
digitale intégrée sous l'écran par
contre vous l'aurez sur la tranche au
niveau du bouton pour l'allumer ce qui
en soi fonctionne aussi très bien c'est
discret c'est pas mal c'est pas remis
complètement de dégager sur la face
arrière
donc ça aussi je trouve que c'est un
excellent choix fait de la part de
samsung est à noter que samsung devrait
supprimer son capteur d'iris donc vous
ne pourrez plus avoir votre facebook
avec votre connaissance à iris tout va
se passer au niveau de votre doigt
c'est un choix stratégique une mais dans
l'absolu 500 plutôt pas mal d'années
maintenant au niveau de l'ouest ça c'est
intéressant il ya une bien vrai
changement au niveau de l'os
on va tourner sous and you and me
tourner lui-même sur android 9 pas
l'idée de loin du rail
c'est de pouvoir utiliser son smartphone
à une seule main très facilement une
interface complètement optimisé pour
l'utilisateur plus simple plus intuitive
plus agréable ça ça peut être
intéressant et on sait en plus que d'un
point de vue logiciel samsung travaille
sur un mode nuit équivalence qu'on peut
retrouver sur le pixel 3 et pixel 3xl de
google
il ya eu un très très gros focus
j'utilise en ce moment moelleux le pixel
3 de google et je puis vous assurer que
le mode nuit et franchement excellent on
fait une photo vous le résultat va pas
terrible vous avez un traitement
derrière ça vous sort un truc
complètement incroyable et justement on
cela trouver un équivalent en tout cas
samsung travaille dessus forcé nouveaux
modèles et ça paye franchement ça hyper
cool un smartphone bien évidemment
complètement boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle vous allez avoir une puce
dié le npi ou complètement dédiée à
l'intelligence artificielle qui va venir
vraiment optimisé d'une la partie photo
l'autonomie la performance il va
vraiment devenir apporter de la
puissance et du jus aux éléments que
vous allez utiliser ça vraiment venir
optimiser tous ceux qui travaillent en
arrière plan pour que vous ayez vraiment
du jus de la batterie faut que ce soit
vraiment vraiment cool vous aurez aussi
plus de dix ans qu'on voudrait
réellement besoin va penser notamment à
des jeux vidéo un peu gros bras face à
va être vraiment cool on devrait
toujours avoir une prise jack et
conserver ça c'est aussi tu as cool de
la recharge bien évidemment en usb tic
c'est de la recharge rapide sans fil ça
c'est aussi cool et il va toujours
conserver une carte micro sd pour
pouvoir rajouter un peu plus de stockage
bon perso je voulais déjà dit dans une
précédente vidéo
l'effet poinçonnage dans l'écran ça me
dérange pas sur un module par contre dès
que vous arrivez sur le double module
l'effet poinçonnage je trouve ça un
petit peu moins joli ça un petit peu
gros après c'est très personnel je pense
que c'est parce que je veux voir pour
une première fois en tout cas sur les
premiers conflits que j'ai pu voir
on verra ça se trouve je vais m'y
habitue et puis il faudrait le
smartphone devant moi si effectivement
il s'avère qu'il est réellement comme ça
ça se trouve les trouver sa toque jeu le
garde nos fils scintillants vachement
bien voilà donc ça on attend va voir
je voudrais vous annoncer la date de
présentation qui est le 20 février
prochain
san francisco londres seoul je vous
invite à vous abonner parce que j'y
serai justement on va en parler
directement pouvez me rejoindre sur
instagram monsieur underscore greu sur
twitter monsieur gros tout attaché vous
verrez vous aurez toutes les infos saas
avec hyper cool et dès le lendemain je
vous sors la vidéo donc ça on va être au
top il devrait y avoir des précommandes
des lendemains des 21 février et on
devrait pouvoir la voir dans les
boutiques l'acheter le recevoir à partir
du 8 mars
à noter également qu'il pourrait y avoir
un modèle qui sortirait un peu plus tard
dans l'année
s'appellerait le s10 x jolie croix avec
de la 5g alors la 5g en europe c'est pas
pour tout de suite les opérateurs il
travaille d'ailleurs on en reparlera au
mwc d'ici quelques jours enfin la
semaine d'après justement j'ai la chance
de pouvoir partir avec qualcomm donc la
question 5 j on va pouvoir en parler
vous allez voir ça va franchement hyper
intéressant mais ça bien évidemment on
en reparlera un peu plus tard alors
qu'en est il du prix c'est là où ça
devient intéressant
j'ai noté quelques informations
là-dessus vous vous en douterez alors le
s10 on prépare déjà trouvé s10 s10 plus
en quatre couleurs blanc noir
jules verne des antisèches bleu et vert
pourquoi pas on verra on devrait avoir
le s10 en version 6 jega drame +128 giga
de stockage à 899 euros
on reste sensiblement dans la même gamme
de tarifs et suite s9 s10 le tarif
augmente toujours un petit peu mais ça
reste dans une dans une échelle qui
enfonce raisonnable on pourra voir une
version 8 gigas de ram 512 giga de
stockage à 1149 euros ça une fois de
plus je vous le dis ça dépend des pays
je pense pas qu'on en europe en tout cas
nous on les le s10 +6 giga de ram 128 go
de stockage à 999 euros soit 100 euros
de plus que les 10 ans d'habitude
c'était pareil avec les suites et suit
plus et s 9 est 9 plus on l'aurait
également en 8 gigas de ram plus 512 ire
de stockage à 1249 euros tout de suite
les prix s'envolent un peu plus et alors
là une version spéciale 12 giga de ram
et un terrain de stockage à 1499 euros
ça ça peut aussi être intéressante à
noter que le s10 e on pourrait la voir
dans les mêmes couleurs noir blanc bleu
et vert mais également dans une couleur
jaune jaune canari je ne poussais
pourquoi pas ça pourrait être sympa si
giga de ram 128 go de stockage à 749
euros
pour se tirer trouver toutes les infos
que j'ai actuellement sur cs 10s 10 plus
s10e a vous de me dire maintenant ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce qui pourrait vous intéresser vous
savez il ya un gros renouvellement des
smartphones de la gamme s galaxy s tous
les deux ans elle suit et la f10 le s9
est un peu un modèle denis génération
like le s10 il devrait y avoir beaucoup
de changements sata est franchement
hyper cool et d'autant plus cette année
va être énorme parce qu'en plus de la
bataille sur le haut de gamme d'une
vraie bataille dans le milieu de gamme
et je compte c'est même là où la guerre
est la plus compliquée pour des marques
comme samsung
parce qu'en face vous avez tous des
smartphones avec des caractéristiques
haut de gamme qui se battent à des
tarifs beaucoup plus bas
donc là dessus c'est aussi très
intéressant on verra tout ça cette année
et en plus de ça il ya une grosse
bagarre sont n'arrive pas c'est la
guerre en ce moment au niveau des
smartphones à écran pliable
quel sera le premier à sortir son
smartphone à écran pliable on a vu le
modèle de rougeole
j'ai testé il ya pas très longtemps le
flex paille bon ça casse pas quelques
pattes à un canard
il faut un peu de pub là dessus mais les
vrais modèles intéressants pour pas
tardé il fut sorti déjà une vidéo où on
voit le modèle de xiaomi utilisé par un
fonds de par son co-fondateur
franchement hyper cool
samsung a présenté le sien très
rapidement lors sa conférence de
développeurs en catimini dans le noir
envoyé juste l'écran pour montrer un
petit peu ça ça va être cool on sait que
huawei travail déçu il ya lg enfin il ya
pas mal de constructeurs donc ça serait
vraiment cool on va beaucoup parler
cette année vous invite donc à vous
abonner pour suivre toute cette actu qui
bien évidemment je compte sur vous pour
marquer tous vos commentaires me dire ce
que vous en pensez si vous avez des
questions suggestions des avis si ce
modèle pourrait vous intéresser oui ou
non et à consulter map les risques qui
doit s'afficher par ci par là où en fin
de vidéo pour voir toute l'actu niveau
des smartphones ça fait plein de choses
à faire c'est hyper cool
d'ici là je vous embrasse donne rendez
vous dès demain et n'oubliez pas on se
retrouve le 20 février à londres ça
aurait du mal à bientôt